Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. What was that? Well, a lot of our listeners will know, Tom, because they're more sophisticated in cosmopolitan than you are. That was Welcome to the Restless History with me, Dominic Sandbrook, and my pitiful servant and slave, Tom Holland. I thought it was probably something along those lines.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告广播、抢先收听系列节目，并加入我们深受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。那是怎么回事？好吧，我们的很多听众都会知道，汤姆，因为他们比你更有品位、更有见识。那是欢迎收听《历史的余烬》，我是多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook），还有我可怜的仆人和奴隶汤姆·霍兰（Tom Holland）。我想大概就是诸如此类的内容吧。
So, Dominic, let's get this straight. You've never learnt Japanese. I imagine you've never in your life before spoken it. Tom, you are so wrong. So we've got a Japanese specialist who's shortly to come on who will tell you, they don't call me, Tom, the master of tongues for nothing, do they? We've had Portuguese.
所以，多米尼克，我们把话说清楚。你从来没学过日语。我想你这辈子以前也从来没说过日语。汤姆，你大错特错了。所以我们请到了一位日语专家，他很快就会上节目来告诉你，汤姆，人们不叫我“语言大师”可不是白叫的，对吧？我们讲过葡萄牙语。
We've had all kinds of languages from me. Yes. Okay. So you have never spoken a word of Japanese in your life. And we have as our special guest, the senior lecturer in Asian history at the University of Edinburgh the author of two hugely acclaimed books on Japan Japan's story in search for nation and the Japanese a history in 20 lives Chris Harding Chris you're still there you haven't run away in horror and shock
我说过各种各样的语言。是的。好吧。所以你这辈子从来没说错过一句日语。而我们的特邀嘉宾是爱丁堡大学亚洲历史高级讲师，著有两本关于日本的广受赞誉的著作——《日本的故事：搜寻国家》和《日本：20人的一生》的克里斯·哈丁（Chris Harding）。克里斯，你还在吗？你没有吓得逃跑吧？
nope enjoying myself so far. Thank you. Well, thanks so much for coming on and thank you for braving that. Thank you. So today's subject obviously is Japan. So we're continuing with our sweet. You don't have the courage. You don't have the courage to ask Chris how good that Japanese was. Chris, how good was that Japanese? It was pretty good, actually.
没有，目前玩得很开心。谢谢。嗯，非常感谢你能来，也谢谢你勇敢地尝试了那个。谢谢。所以今天的主题显然是日本。所以我们要延续这个系列。你没有勇气。你没有勇气问克里斯那段日语说得有多好。克里斯，那段日语说得怎么样？其实相当不错。
Yes. No. No. Yes. No! No! Tom! I think we should end this podcast right now and start again. The producers should clip that moment and put it on YouTube. Oh my word. Oh no! Unbelievable. That's terrible. Chris, so we've asked you on to do basically the impossible,
是的。不。不。是的。不！不！汤姆！我想我们现在就应该结束这期播客并重新开始。制作人们应该把那个片段剪辑下来发到YouTube上。我的天啊。哦，不！难以置信。太糟糕了。克里斯，我们请你来基本上是完成不可能的任务，
which is to sum up the entire sweep of Japanese history. We did a very fleeting episode, didn't we, on Kuber Khan's attempted invasion of Japan. And we did two episodes with Rana Mitter on China in the Second World War, which obviously featured Japan as a kind of offstage bogeyman. But we haven't really looked at Japan itself. And I would say that of all the countries in the world whose history I know nothing about, Japan is the country I would most like to know about. And it kind of, I would guess that most of our listeners probably don't know huge amounts about Japanese history. And yet we all have this kind of sense of it. It has such, its history has such a strong presence in the imagination. Samurai anduki and manga manga and all that kind of stuff um and yet japan itself i mean it's it emerges when kind of sixth seventh century i
那就是总结日本历史的全貌。我们做过一期非常短暂的节目，不是吗，关于忽必烈汗试图入侵日本。我们和拉纳·米特（Rana Mitter）一起做了两期关于中国在第二次世界大战中的节目，其中显然将日本描绘成了一个幕后的可怕恶魔。但我们并没有真正审视日本本身。而且我想说，在世界上所有我一无所知的国家中，日本是我最想了解的国家。而且我猜，我们的大多数听众可能对日本历史也不是非常了解。然而我们对它都有这种感觉。它的历史在想象中有着如此强大的存在感。武士、艺伎、漫画等等诸如此类的一切……然而日本本身，我的意思是，它出现于大约六、七世纪，我
think that's right as a unified the beginnings of a nation state yes around the sixth uh sixth century early seventh so the islands have obviously they've they have always been there, but what is it that creates Japan as a sort of unified... Is nation state the right word, actually? Is nation state the right word for a 7th century construct? Well, I suppose it begins, obviously, centuries before that. Even in recorded time, we have evidence from Chinese records of there being this place, Land of the Dwarves or various other unfortunate names that it gets given. But at that point, it's really a series of
想这没错，作为一个统一的民族国家的萌芽，是的，大约在第六、七世纪初——所以这些岛屿显然一直都在那里，但究竟是什么创造了日本这样一个统一的……其实“民族国家”这个词准确吗？对于一个7世纪的建制来说，“民族国家”这个词准确吗？嗯，我想它显然在几个世纪前就开始了。甚至在有记载的时期，我们从中国记录中就有证据表明有这个地方，“侏儒之国”或其他被赋予的各种不幸的名字。但到那时，它实际上是一系列
small chiefdoms spread across this massive archipelago. I suppose what you could say it moves towards, if not a nation state, then one of the chiefdoms or one of these clans, the Yamato clan, starts to be able to dominate and do business with others, really not far from Tokyo, Osaka, Kyoto type area for modern Japan. And they become dominant clan, they start to talk about themselves as the great kings. And this is the beginning of the imperial family that we have in Japan today. So Chris, the actual name Japan, I learned from your book, The Japanese History in 20 Lives. It's Nihon, which means root of the sun. And this is how the Japanese emperor addresses
分散在这个巨大群岛上的小型酋长邦。我想你可以说它正朝着这个方向发展，如果不是民族国家的话，那么其中一个酋长邦或氏族——大和氏族（Yamato clan）开始能够主导并与其他人开展业务，实际上距离现代日本的东京、大阪、京都地区不远。他们成为了主导氏族，开始称自己为“大王”。这就是今天日本皇室的开端。所以克里斯，“日本”这个真名，我是从你的书《日本：20人的一生》中了解到的。是 Nihon，意思是“太阳之本”。这就是日本天皇向
himself to the Chinese emperor, who is splendidly dismissive, isn't he? He kind of says, do not bring this to my attention again. Presumption has occurred. In your book, The Japanese History in 20 Lives, you've divided, obviously, into 20 lives. Yes. That goes without saying. But you, for us, have chosen six lives. So who is your first life? So let's call it Japan emerges in the 7th century AD. Who is our first? Yeah, I think the first person really worth talking about would be Murasaki Shikibu, who
中国皇帝呈信时对自己的称呼，中国皇帝对此表现得非常不屑，对吧？他基本上说：“不要再拿这种事来烦我了。这是僭越。”在你的书《日本：20人的一生》中，你显然把它分成了20个人的一生。是的。这是不言而喻的。但你为我们挑选了六个人的一生。那么你的第一个人是谁？所以我们可以称之为“日本在公元7世纪崛起”，我们的第一个人是谁？是的，我想真正值得谈论的第一个人应该是紫式部（Murasaki Shikibu），她
was around in the late 10th and early 11th century. And she is an aristocratic diarist, a lady-in-waiting to the Empress. I think she's worth talking about because this is the point in Japan's history where after a few centuries of getting a lot of cultural influence from China, particularly on things like constitutional law,
生活在10世纪末和11世纪初。她是一位贵族日记作家，也是皇后身边的女官。我认为她值得一谈，因为这是日本历史上的一个转折点：在经历了几个世纪从中国获得大量文化影响（特别是在宪法、
on poetry, on fashion, on good manners and behaviour, Japan is starting to, I suppose you might say, process that and make something distinctively Japanese of it. And she's famous, isn't she, for The Tale of Genji, which is often described as the first kind of great novel from Asia. That's right. The first novel, the world's first psychological novel, you could say. I think she's interesting because she's a brilliant observer of court life in Japan. You know, we were talking moments ago about the Yamato clan who gradually managed to turn themselves into this imperial clan. By the time of Murasaki Shikibu, they've established themselves in what we would call Kyoto now, which is Heian-kyo back in the day. And she's at court observing, I think
诗歌、时尚、好习惯和礼仪等方面）之后，日本开始——我想你可以这么说——消化这些影响，并从中创造出具有日本独特性的东西。她因《源氏物语》（The Tale of Genji）而闻名，对吧？这本书通常被描述为亚洲第一部伟大的小说。没。第一部小说，可以说是世界上第一部心理小说。我认为她很有趣，因为她是日本宫廷生活的杰出观察者。你知道，我们刚才还在讨论大和氏族，他们逐渐设法把自己变成这个皇室氏族。到紫式部生活的时代，他们已经在我们现在所说的京都（当时称为平安京）确立了地位。她在宫廷里观察着，我想
what a lot of Japanese would probably say now is one of the high points of Japanese culture and Japanese civilization. So she's there, she's observing the chapter on her I have starting off with her diary, actually observing the birth of a child to the Empress Shoshi. It just gives a sense of, I think from her, we get a sense of the vivid religious life. You've got this teenage girl on this raised dais behind white curtains in labour. It's going very badly. And you've got these Buddhist priests praying. You've got exorcists. You've got diviners.
很多日本人现在可能会说，这是日本文化和日本文明的高峰之一。所以她在那里，她在观察，我书里关于她的那一章其实就是从她的日记开始的，观察着彰子皇后（Empress Shoshi）产子。这给人一种感觉，我想从她那里，我们能感受到生动的宗教生活。你有一个十几岁的女孩，在产房里白色的窗帘后面高高的台子上。情况非常糟糕。还有佛教僧侣在祈祷。还有驱魔师。还有占卜师。
You've got exorcists, you've got diviners, you've got shamans. You've also got a crowd of people on look as aristocrats gathered round just beyond that curtain to wait for the big moment. So if you didn't have someone like Murasaki at that point, noting this culture for us, remembering it so richly for us, it would just be, you know, an imperial birth that either happened or didn't happen. But thanks to her, and also I think thanks to the art of this period, we remember it, I think both Japanese and people outside Japan, as a real classical high point for Japan. The kind of time when you probably, one of those two or three moments in Japanese history where you might really like to have been alive and be part of that world. Except for the lack of dentistry, I suppose. Yeah. So to put that into context, she's what? She's probably, Tom, you'll correct me if I'm wrong about this, but she's roughly about the same time as Ethelred the Unready.
还有驱魔师，还有占卜师，还有萨满。在那道帘子外面，还聚集了一群贵族围观者，等待着那个重大时刻的到来。所以，如果没有像紫式部这样的人在那个时候为我们记录这种文化，为我们如此丰富地记住它，它就只是一场发生了或者没发生过的皇室分娩。但多亏了她，我想也多亏了这个时期的艺术，我们——无论是日本本地人还是日本以外的人——都把它记作了日本真正的古典黄金时期。这是一个你可能会觉得——日本历史上那一两个你可能真的很想活在其中并成为那个世界一部分的时期。除了缺乏牙科医术之外，我想是的。是的，为了把这放到背景中去，她大约是？汤姆，如果我记错了请纠正我，但她大概和“无准备者埃塞尔雷德”（Ethelred the Unready）是同一时期的人。
Yes. Is that about right, Tom? Yes. So that's not her real name, Murasaki Shikibu. We don't know her real name. Is that right? Her real name is just lost or was hidden or was secret? I think it's a testament to the times that women's real names were of not much interest to people, so they didn't tend to be recorded in the way that men's would be. We think probably Shikibu comes from her father's post, Shikibu no Daijo. So he was a senior secretarial post in the government. And Murasaki either is a nickname given to her at court from one of the characters of The Tale of Genji. While she was at court working as a lady in waiting, she was drafting chapters of The Tale of Genji, passing them around for feedback amongst
是的。差不多是这样吗，汤姆？是的。所以那不是她的真名，紫式部。我们不知道她的真名。是这样吗？她的真名只是遗失了，还是被隐藏了，或者是个秘密？我认为这证明了当时的时代：女性的真名对人们来说并不怎么受关注，所以它们不像男性的名字那样容易被记录下来。我们认为“式部”可能来自她父亲的职位——式部大丞（Shokibu no Daijo）。因此他在政府中担任高级秘书职位。而“紫”要么是宫廷中人根据《源氏物语》中的一个角色给她的绰号。当她在宫廷担任女官时，她正在起草《源氏物语》的章节，并在
other courtiers. So some may have given her that name from one of the big characters in the book. The other possibility is, and it's a bit more circuitous, that Murasaki in Japanese means purple. And she was from a very junior branch of the Fujiwara aristocratic family. And Fuji means wisteria, which is, of course, purple. So it's possible that it came via that, as I say, more circuitous route. What would be quite significant there, I think, is that she was part of this dominant family, because although the imperial family by this point have written themselves into a semi-fake history of Japan that they put together, there are still very powerful aristocratic families with these amazing mansions around Heian-kyo who are vying for power. And the
其他朝臣之间传阅以征求反馈。所以有些人可能会根据书中的一个重要角色给她起了这个名字。另一种可能性是——而且稍微有点曲折——“紫”在日语中是紫色的意思。她来自藤原贵族家族的一个非常低微的分支。而“藤”（Fuji）的意思是紫藤，当然也就是紫色的。所以它可能是通过这种——正如我所说——更曲折的路线得来的。我认为这里非常重要的一点是，她是这个主导家族的一部分，因为尽管到这个时候，皇室已经把自己编入了一部他们拼凑出来的半虚构的日本历史中，但在平安京周围仍然有非常强大的贵族家族，他们拥有这些宏伟的宅邸，正在争夺权力。而
Fujiwara family are easily the most powerful of those, I think. And what she gives us is a sense of incredible psychological sophistication, but also cultural sophistication. And a lot of what she's describing kind of corresponds perhaps to the stereotypes that people have of Japan. So among the pleasures that Ulysses Cortes is doing is blossom viewing. And the blossom in Japan is incredibly famous. And also you describe how women look at this court and white powdered skin with rouge cheeks and red lips alongside painted eyebrows and blackened teeth. And that is very much the kind of the stereotype of the geisha, I guess. Are these continuities or not?
藤原家族无疑是其中最强大的，我认为。而她带给我们的是一种令人难以置信的心理成熟度，还有文化成熟度。她所描述的很多内容可能与人们对日本的刻板印象相吻合。因此，宫廷贵族们的乐趣之一就是赏花。日本的赏花活动非常有名。此外，你还描述了这个宫廷里的女性外观：白粉扑面的脸颊、红唇，画着的眉毛以及熏黑的牙齿。这非常符合艺伎的刻板印象，我想。这些是延续下来的传统吗，还是别的什么？
I think they are. One of the remarkable things about Japan's history from this period onwards is probably in Murasaki's day, this is the last era where the emperor in Japan has any real kind of power. So listeners will be aware after that, we move into shoguns and samurai. And then in the modern era, we have something that looks like a Western government. And yet lots of these aspiring leaders in Japan across centuries, in fact, they managed to sideline the emperor or shut them away or whatever they do to them. They always aspire to some kind of imperial legitimacy, some kind of imperial culture. So the culture of Murasaki's era, the aesthetics that you've just talked about, that remains a kind of touchstone for refinement in Japan. I know that can be almost a cliche when we talk about Japan, the idea of refinement, but... We're all about cliches here.
我认为是的。从这个时期开始，日本历史最显著的特点之一可能就是，在紫式部的时代，这是日本天皇拥有任何真正权力的最后一个时代。所以听众们会知道，在那之后，我们进入了幕府将军和武士的时代。而在现代，我们拥有了一个看起来像西方政府的东西。然而，几个世纪以来，日本许多有抱负的领导人——事实上，他们设法将天皇边缘化、把他们关起来或者对他们做了别的什么。他们总是渴望某种皇室的合法性，某种皇室文化。因此，紫式部时代的文化、你刚才谈到的美学，仍然是日本精致的基准。我知道当我们谈论日本时，这几乎可能成了一种陈词滥调——精致的概念，但是……我们这里全都是陈词滥调。
Good. I think for a culture, maybe there's a parallel with us in the UK here. So much of Japanese culture over the centuries comes in from abroad. So China, later on it's Europe, later on it's the US. So the Japanese come to pride themselves on refining what comes in from Chinese poetry to the transistor and doing something special with it. And if you ask, I think your average Japanese man or woman on the street, what would they say epitomizes refinement in Japan? It's probably the world that Murasaki talks about. You made the comparison with England. So the age of Ethelred, the Unready. The idea of a psychological novel coming out of that period is almost unthinkable, unfathomable. How is it that Japan in the 10th century is able to produce a psychological novel? It's a great question. I
很好。对于一种文化来说，也许这里与我们英国有相似之处。几个世纪以来，日本的大量文化都是从国外输入的。所以是中国，后来是欧洲，再后来是美国。因此，日本人开始以提炼外来之物为傲——从中国诗歌到晶体管，并用它们做出特别的东西。如果你问街头一个普通的日本男人或女人，什么能体现日本的精致？那可能就是紫式部所谈论的世界。你把它和英格兰进行了比较。所以是埃塞尔雷德无准备者时代。从那个时期涌现出一部心理小说，几乎是不可想象、不可思议的。为什么10世纪的日本能够产生一部心理小说？这是一个很好的问题。我
think probably a couple of things. One is the importance of Chinese poetry in Japanese culture. So you've got a tradition of reflection, which is aesthetically and emotionally really deep, and I think very well established. The other element is that at court, there's a tradition already by this point of aristocratic women in particular, who don't have much by way of a day job because the men are monopolising government roles, writing these diaries, these miscellanies. So I suppose, say, Sean O'Gon's Pillow Book, people may have heard of that. Wasn't it Ewan McGregor was in that film, if I remember right? He was, yeah.
想原因大概有几个。首先是中国诗歌在日本文化中的重要性。所以你拥有一个传统，这种反省在审美和情感上都非常深厚，而且我认为已经非常成熟。另一个因素是，在宫廷里，当时已经有一个传统，尤其是贵族女性——由于男人们垄断了政府职位，她们没有什么正经工作——她们会写日记、杂记。所以我想，比如清少纳言的《枕草子》，人们可能听说过。伊万·麦克格雷格（Ewan McGregor）不是演过那部电影吗，如果我没记错的话？他是，是的。
Is that right? Oh, good. So I think there's that tradition, and it's particularly in women's writing, of observing people at court and their attempts to be refined and their attempts at one-upmanship in everything from poetry to cherry blossom viewing to clothing. I think that's where it comes from. That's why Murasaki is so valuable. But, you know, we're going to go on and talk about Oda Nobunaga next. I suppose the remarkable thing is that some of that can be lost. So it's not as though Japan enters what you might call dark ages exactly, but some of that refinement almost completely goes away or it's confined to perhaps the emperor's palace in Kyoto. And it doesn't really, for many centuries, become emblematic of Japan again.
是这样吗？哦，太好了。所以我想有这个传统，特别是在女性的写作中，观察宫廷里的人，观察他们对精致的追求，以及他们在从诗歌、赏花到服饰等各个方面想要胜过别人的企图。我想这就是它的来源。这就是为什么紫式部如此珍贵。但是，你知道，我们接下来要谈谈织田信长（Oda Nobunaga）。我想值得注意的是，其中一些东西可能会失传。所以并不是说日本进入了所谓的黑暗时代，但其中一些精致几乎完全消失了，或者它仅限于京都的天皇宫殿。而且几个世纪以来，它并没有真正再次成为日本的象征。
So Murasaki kind of embodies absolutely the stereotype that outsiders have of Japan as a place of delicacy and sophistication, perhaps kind of feminine sense of delicacy and sophistication. But equally, you mentioned this guy, Oda Nobunaga, if I pronounced his name right, who is absolutely the opposite. So he is 16th century and he's an absolute lad, isn't he? I mean, he is going around kicking sand in people's faces and he's the embodiment of that. Is he a samurai? He's a shogun, I guess. He's a samurai. He doesn't become shogun, but he becomes in effect ruler of this realm that he's trying to stitch together.
所以紫式部某种程度上完美地体现了局外人对日本的刻板印象——一个充满精致和细腻的地方，也许是一种女性化的精致和细腻感。但同样，你提到了这个人，织田信长，如果我把他的名字读对的话，他绝对是相反的。所以他是16世纪的人，他绝对是个狂人，不是吗？我的意思是，他到处往别人脸上踢沙子，他是这方面的化身。他是武士吗？我想他是个幕府将军。他是武士。他没有成为幕府将军，但他实际上成为了他试图拼凑起来的这个王国的统治者。
That's right. I suppose since Murasaki's time in those intervening centuries, what's happened is that the imperial power in Kyoto is on the wane and instead you get these feudal lords and we start talking about samurai at that point who were vying amongst themselves for real power in Japan.
没错。我想自从紫式部时代以来，在中间的几个世纪里，发生的事情是京都的皇室权力正在衰落，取而代之的是这些封建领主，我们在那个时候开始谈论武士，他们在日本争夺真正的权力。
You have a series of military governments with a shogun at the head. And Oda Nobunaga is born into this era of real complete chaos in Japan, civil war between these different feudal lords. And he more or less comes out on top. He's one of three great warrior leaders in a row. He's the first of three. And the final one manages more or less to pacify the whole of Japan. 250 years of peace until the West turn up in the middle of the 19th century. So Oda Nobunaga, he's a really important, really important figure. But as you say, he accomplishes most of what he does by being
你有一系列由幕府将军领导的军事政府。而织田信长出生在这个日本真正陷入彻底混乱的时代，这些不同的封建领主之间爆发了内战。而他或多或少脱颖而出。他是连续三位伟大的武士领袖中的第一位。最后一位设法或多或少平定了整个日本。直到19世纪中叶西方人出现之前，这里迎来了250年的和平。所以织田信长，他是一个非常重要、非常重要的人物。但正如你所说，他完成的大部分成就都归功于他
extraordinarily bloodthirsty, a mixture of very bloodthirsty and a really good strategist i think you'd probably say and how typical is he of samurai so for those people who don't know maybe give us a tiny sense of you know i mean everybody knows what a samurai looks like but what are they and what's their sort of function originally they were they operated as bodyguards and that the word comes from um the verb to serve so they would serve um some of these uh characters in the imperial capital heian kya who got into all sorts of trouble with each other you know you might in the end have a samurai standing outside your door at night if you're a slightly anxious aristocrat um but over the intervening time, it's much more
极其嗜血，可以说是非常嗜血与非常出色的战略家的结合。那么他作为武士有多典型呢？对于那些不知道的人，也许可以给我们讲一点（你知道，我的意思是每个人都知道武士长什么样，但他们是什么，他们的职能是什么？）最初他们的作用是保镖，这个词来自“服务”这个动词，所以他们会为平安京皇城里的一些人服务，那些人彼此陷入了各种麻烦中。你知道，如果你是一个稍微有些焦虑的贵族，你最后可能会在夜里看到一个武士站在你的门外。但在随后的时间里，它更多地
about honourable war making. There's a blend there, I think, with Zen Buddhism and with the aesthetics of Zen. So by Oda Nobunaga's time, to be a samurai isn't just to go around killing people, it's to have a really good knowledge of Japanese poetry. He likes to dance and sing from Noel plays. So there's a cultured element to him, but you wouldn't say that culture adds up to a conscience in his case. The standard parallels with knights. Is that reasonable? I mean, that's sort of the chivalric ideal of the knight who's killing people and thinking about Jesus. Is that fair? In the modern era, this was really played up because the Japanese wanted to claim the Samurais being as honourable as the European chivalric tradition. But I think there is
关乎荣誉之战。这里面有一种融合，我认为，包括禅宗以及禅宗的美学。所以在织田信长时代，成为一名武士不仅是到处杀人，还要对日本诗歌有很好的了解。他喜欢跳能剧（Noh plays）的舞蹈和唱歌。所以他身上有文人的一面，但在他身上，你不能说这种文化能转化为良知。与骑士的标准进行类比。这合理吗？我的意思是，这有点像骑士的骑士精神理想，他们杀人同时又想着耶稣。这公平吗？在现代，这一点被大大夸大了，因为日本人希望宣称武士与欧洲的骑士传统一样光荣。但我认为
something there because honour is an enormous part of it. A hierarchy is extraordinarily important. And there is an element of a religious sense of sending your enemies into the void. So I'd say there's there are parallels there yes to an extent with europe of course what knights don't have the little flag that they that the samurai wore on their back which i think is a great tradition um because yes yes they have it in rand don't they the the great kind of reworking of king lear amazing spectacle of armies with samurai warriors with the flags fluttering over their heads. Absolutely. I suppose it's directors like Kurosawa that we have to thank
里面确实有某种东西，因为荣誉是其中极其重要的一部分。等级制度极其重要。而且这里有一种宗教感，即把你的敌人送入虚空。所以我想说，这在某种程度上与欧洲有相似之处，是的。当然，骑士没有那种武士背上佩戴的小旗子，我认为那是一个伟大的传统，因为——是的，是的，他们在《乱》（Ran）里有，对吧？黑泽明对《李尔王》的伟大改编，展现了武士军队头顶旗帜飘扬的惊人奇观。绝对的。我想我们要感谢黑泽明这样的导演，才让我们对武士产生了这种兴趣。是的。所以具体说到这家伙信长，你说他很残酷。是的。所以他似乎将他的对手——军阀们作为目标，把他们打倒在地，并开始拼凑出将成为日本的东西。而且他对佛教徒也非常残酷，不是吗？他不喜欢佛教徒。是的。我的意思是，在当时的日本，因为几个世纪以来有太多的混乱，一些大的佛教宗派已经把自己武装起来了。在其中一些山顶寺庙里，你基本上有武装僧侣。如果你想引入一个欧洲的类比，
for this interest in samurai to some extent anyway. Yeah. So specifically this guy Nobunaga, you said that he's brutal. Yes. So he seems to, he targets his kind of rival warlords and knocks them out of the way and starts to stitch together what will become, I guess, Japan. And he's also very brutal towards Buddhists, isn't he? He doesn't like Buddhists. Yeah. I mean, at this point in Japan, because there's been so much chaos over centuries, some of the big Buddhist sects have armed themselves. You've got basically warrior monks on some of these mountaintop temples. You've also got, if there's a European parallel to bring in here,
你有一个佛教宗派，净土真宗（Jodo Shinshu），它是日本式的清教徒主义，植根于这个名为亲鸾圣人（Shinran Shonin）的人的工作，他有点像日本的马丁·路德，他基本上说你不需要经历各种苦行等。你只需念一句简短的祈祷给阿弥陀佛，你就能得救。这在战斗中非常有用，因为如果净土真宗决定这样做，他们可以把大量相对普通的人送上对抗织田信长的战场。有些人会带着写有这个祈祷文（念佛）的小纸片进入战场。他们无所畏惧。他们
you've got one sect of Buddhism, Jodo Shinshu, which is a sort of Japanese equivalent of Protestantism, rooted in the work of this guy, Shinran Shonin, who's a kind of Japanese Martin Luther, who basically says that you don't have to go through all sorts of ascetic practices, etc. You just have one short prayer to say to Amida Buddha and you'll be saved. And this is incredibly useful in a fight because Jodo Shinshu can put lots of relatively ordinary people on the battlefield against Oda Nobunaga if they decide to do so. And some people will carry little pieces of paper into battle with this prayer, the Nimbutsu, written on it. They are fearless. They come
从天而降。他们得到了当地商人的很好资助。对于像织田信长这样的人来说，将宗教与武装力量结合在一起是一场绝对的灾难。所以他对于试图消灭这些人表现得异常残忍。他不相信上帝，他不相信灵魂不朽，不相信来世。不，他似乎没有这些。他似乎相信今世的安全。所以他大约有2000名保镖。这非常“桑德布鲁克”，非常符合桑德布鲁克风格，我赞同他。所以他——嗯，他几乎是个独裁者，对吧？但他没有让自己——他似乎从未想过让自己成为天皇，推翻皇室，赶走这个王朝。
out of nowhere. They're quite well funded by local merchants. And for someone like Oda Nobunaga, it's an absolute disaster to have that marriage of religion with armed power. So he's extraordinarily brutal about trying to wipe these people out. And he't believe in god he doesn't believe in immortality of the soul doesn't believe in life after death no he doesn't seem to have any of that he seems to believe in decent security in this life so he's got about 2 000 bodyguards it's very sandbroke very sandbrokean i approve of him so he um well he's he's virtually dictator isn't he but he doesn't make himself, it never occurs to him, it seems, to make himself emperor, to overthrow the imperial family, kick out the dynasty.
我的意思是，为什么不呢？为什么他不把他们扫地出门，自己掌权呢？我想因为在日本，天皇——我们一开始提到的大和家族——已经把神圣起源的神话融入了他们的故事中。所以故事是太阳神的后代，是这样吗？
I mean, why not? Why doesn't he get rid? Because, I mean, they are, you describe in your book that they basically, they adopt him because they don't want to be seen to be cowering before a dictator. So why doesn't he just sweep them aside and take power himself? I think because in Japan, the emperors, this Yamato family that we mentioned towards the beginning, they've worked a myth of divine origins into their story. So descended from the sun is the story, is that right?
是的，按照他们的说法，是来自太阳神天照大神（Amaterasu）。无论——你知道——日本人在不同时期实际上有多大程度上相信这一点，这其实很难辨别。但他们身上有一种光环，如果你进去对他们采取任何暴力行为，那将成为你的敌人团结起来对付你的最佳借口。你必须向皇室表达敬意。所以根本无法摆脱他们。有些人认为织田本可以轻松获得“征夷大将军”的称号，大致意思是“镇压蛮族的将军”。我很想要这个称号。谁不想当那个呢？
Yeah, from the sun goddess Amaterasu in their version of events. And whether, you know, the extent to which people in Japan in different periods actually believe that is rather hard to discern. But there's an aura about them that to go in and commit any acts of violence against them would be the ideal basis on which your enemies could then unite and come for you. You have to pay respects to the imperial family. So there's no getting rid of then. Some people think that Oda could have easily taken the title of Shogun, which is kind of barbarian crushing generalissimo, roughly means. I'd love to have that title. Who wouldn't want to be that?
把它印在你的名片上。是的，但他其实不需要那样做，因为他拥有足够的实际权力，头衔并不意味着太多。他一生都在奔波，他总是在寻找下一个战场在哪里，以便去战斗并赢得胜利。他对坐在京都无所事事、处理行政事务并不是特别感兴趣。事实上，在他死的时候，日本还有相当一部分领土等待被征服。所以是的，他手头依然有很多事要忙。而且他迎来了相当悲惨的结局，不是吗？我的意思是，他并没有在一片日本人民的欢呼声中骑马走向夕阳，对吧？没有。而且我想，如果事情发生在500年前，这也不能算剧透吧，但他发现自己被敌人包围了——那些曾经是盟友的人，一个叫明智光秀（Akechi Mitsuhide）的家伙，带着他的军队背叛了他，放火烧了寺庙，
Put that on your business card. Yeah, but then he doesn't really need to do that because he's got enough real power that titles don't mean terribly much.'s a man his entire life he's always on the move he's always looking to see where the next battle uh is to be fought and won he's not terribly interested in in sitting still in kyoto and getting on with the administration there's actually still a fair amount of japan left to be conquered by the time he dies so yeah he still had plenty on his plate and he comes to a fairly sticky end doesn't he I mean he doesn't he doesn't sort of ride off into the sunset to the cheers of the Japanese people does he no and I suppose it's not exactly spoilers if it happened what 500 years ago but he finds himself surrounded by his enemies people who were allies this guy called Akechi Mitsuhide, who, with his troops, turns on him, sets fire to the temple
织田信长和一些最亲密的盟友就困在那里。这座建筑彻底被烧为平地，他在里面切腹自尽，并在最后一刻大喊叛国。有些人会说，他对大量敌人做过非常类似的事情，所以这在某种程度上也是恶有恶报。然而，他当时还很年轻。如果他活下来，他本可以做出更大的成就，但事情并没有那样发展。
where Oda Nobunaga, some of his closest allies, are holed up. And the thing completely burns to the ground, and he takes his life inside, crying treason at the last minute. Some would say that he did very similar things to a large number of his enemies, so there's a certain amount of comeuppance in that. But nevertheless, he was still young. He could have done a great deal more if he'd survived, but that's not the way it went.
在我们在继续之前，有一个非常简短的问题，那就是自杀这件事。是的。这在你的书中的几个人身上都有发生。所以你有20个传主。是的。其中不止几个人选择了自杀。所以西方的刻板印象是，日本人，你知道，迫不及待地想要自杀。所以西方的刻板印象是，日本人迫不及待地想要自杀。
That, just a very quick point before we move on, that thing of taking your own life. Yes. That happens to a few of the people in your book. So you have 20 lives. Yes. And more than a few of them take their own lives. So the Western stereotype is that the Japanese, you know, can't wait them take their own lives. So the Western stereotype is that the Japanese can't wait to take their own lives.
他们有点像罗马将军。用剑切腹。是的，他们有点像公元前1世纪左右的罗马将军。距离体面的结局只有一次失败之遥。这是一种公平的比较，还是我们——这是一种东方主义的视角？是的，我认为这其实不太公平。诚然，对于自杀，并不存在你在基督教
They're sort of like Roman generals. Disembowel themselves with a sword. Yeah, they're like Roman generals in the sort of first century BC or something. Only one defeat away from a sort of noble end. Is that a fair comparison or is it something that we, is that a sort of orientalizing perspective? Yeah, I don't think it is terribly fair. It's certainly true that there isn't the same kind of philosophical or theological objection to taking your life that you might find in a Christian
文化中可能会发现的同等哲学或神学上的反对意见。没有“这是一种罪过”的概念。你可能会出于多种原因这样做，包括为某事承担责任、在你的领主死时或死后自杀，以及——你知道——一直到真正的绝望。所以你可能会这样做，其原因可能更加广泛。但我会说，这并不等于说他们急切地渴望去死。对。伊瑞斯，你引用了一首关于信长和他直接继承人的儿歌——信长舂米，秀吉做糕，家康吃掉。所以家康基本上继承了这个被他的前两任“舂过和做过”的日本。而家康就是德川（Tokugawa），也就是德川幕府。
culture. There's no idea that it's a sin. There are a range of reasons why you might do it, including taking responsibility for something, taking your life at or after the death of your Lord, as well as, you know, all the way across to real despair. So there are probably a broader range of reasons why you might do it. But I would say that's not the same as being desperately eager to do it. Right. Iris you quote uh what a playground verse about nobunaga and his immediate heir so nobunaga pounded the rice hideyoshi baked the cake and ieyasu ate it so ieyasu basically inherits this emperor of japan that um that these his two predecessors have pounded and baked and ieyasu is the tokug, as in the Tokugawa shogunate.
而德川幕府将欧洲人挡在了外面，不是吗？它建立了一种隐世的和平。这可能是人们对日本历史最普遍、最主流的印象，你觉得呢？我认为很可能是这样。我们从西方的角度来看待日本的历史，这是不可避免的。所以从西方的角度来看，这个时代的日本人——我们指的是1600年代初到1800年代中期——对与大多数欧洲国家做生意不感兴趣。因为那是为什么呢？那只是荷兰人去长崎。是的，只有荷兰人。我认为从日本人的角度来看，这是完全合乎情理的。他们刚刚经历了几十年耶稣会传教士制造大量皈依者并干涉他们政治的历史。其中一些封建领主实际上皈依了基督教。当他们这样做时，他们的忠诚究竟在哪里并不十分清楚。所以对于日本人来说，权衡贸易带来的金钱与葡萄牙和西班牙等帝国力量的干涉，这真是一个不用动脑筋的决定。把他们挡在外面更有意义。而荷兰人明确反对出于任何宗教原因留在日本，他们纯粹是商人，他们会对日本人这样说。只有荷兰人，而且他们被限制在一个叫出岛（Dejima）的微小人工岛上，离长崎海岸仅几英尺远，由一座有守卫的桥梁连接。他们受到了亲切的对待，但日本人对他们并没有太大兴趣。所以从西方的角度来看，日本人是在自我孤立。
And the Tokugawa shogunate, it keeps the Europeans out, doesn't it? And it establishes this kind of hermit peace. And it's probably the image of Japan, perhaps, that most popularly dominates people's sense of the history of Japan, do you think? I think possibly. It's inevitable, I think, isn't it, that we see Japan's history from a Western perspective. So from a Western perspective, the Japanese in this era, and we're talking about early 1600s through to middle of the 1800s, were not interested in doing business with most European countries. Because what is it? It's just the Dutch go to Nagasaki. Yeah, it's just the Dutch. And I think from the Japanese point of view, it makes an enormous amount of sense. They've just been through a few decades of having
但实际上从日本内部来看，他们在与东南亚贸易，在与朝鲜、中国贸易。这可能是第二个伟大的时代，许多日本人现在回首时会感到自豪和幸福。汤姆，日本人对待荷兰人的方式和我对你的一样：亲切，但兴趣缺缺。是的，你确实是个幕府将军。作为这个时期的代表人物，你选择了另一位作家。这就是井原西鹤（Ihara Saikaku）。我把名字读对了吗？是的，井原西鹤。是的。那你为什么选择他呢？
Jesuit missionaries making large amounts of converts meddling in their politics. Some of these feudal lords actually convert to Christianity. And it's not really clear where their loyalties lie when they do that. And so for the Japanese, the money to be made from trade weighed up against the meddling from imperial powers like Portugal and Spain. It's really a no-brainer. It makes much more sense to keep them out. And the Dutch, who are expressly against the idea of being in Japan for any kind of religious reasons, they're purely traders, they would say to the Japanese. It's just the Dutch and they're kept on this tiny artificial island called Dejima, a few feet off the coast of Nagasaki, linked by a guarded bridge. And they're treated kindly, but they're of little interest to the Japanese. So there is a sense from a Western point of view that the Japanese are cutting themselves off.
我在书中想做的一件事，就是尽量让人们领略这个时期的部分文学和艺术，而不仅仅是叙述历史基础。井原非常棒，因为他在早年——也许我们一会儿会有一个简短的引言——从写非常美丽、非常感人的诗歌，转变为在他的某本书中创造了一个极好的角色，名叫世之介（Yonosuke），意思是“世界之人”。这个年轻人游历了日本城市文化（如京都和大阪）的所有高潮和低谷，
But actually from the inside of Japan, they're trading with Southeast Asia, they're trading with Korea, with China. And it's probably a second great era on which a lot of Japanese now would look back with pride and happiness. Tom, the Japanese treat the Dutch the same way that I do, kindly, but with little interest. Yes, you are indeed a shogun. As the representative figure of this period, you have chosen another writer. And this is Ihara Saikaku. Have I pronounced that right? Yes, Ihara Saikaku. Yes. So why have you chosen him?
一路上享受着各种乐趣，陷入了各种麻烦。这是一种可爱的方式，仿佛带我们游览了17世纪的日本。他有点像卡萨诺瓦（Casanova）式的人物，你会这么说吗？是的，绝对是。所以他——为了给你引述他的一小段话，出自这本书的一部分，这本书叫《好色一代男》（The Life of an Amorous Man），它讲述了你溜进浴缸的大部分内容。她确信周围没有人。如果有什么声音的话，那一定是不远处松树间的晚风叹息。所以无论如何想着，她开始用米糠肥皂和毛巾使劲擦洗自己。水非常舒适。她特别喜欢洗掉
One of the things I wanted to do in the book is try to give people a flavour of some of the literature and the art from this period, rather than just narrate the historical basics. And Ihara is fantastic because he goes early in life, maybe we'll have a brief quote in a minute, from writing very beautiful, very moving poetry to creating this fabulous character in one of his books called Yonosuke, means man of the world. And it's this young man who tours around all the highlights and the lowlights of Japanese urban culture in places like Kyoto and Osaka,
身体下部的污垢。突然间，仿佛出于本能，她抬起头，看到旁边茶馆的瓦屋顶上，蹲着世之介那个男孩的身影，正用一柄长望远镜对准她。所以这是他很年轻时的作品，但它让你感受到他的兴趣所在。但我也认为，如果我们回想起紫式部那个真正精致的时期，井原在他的作品中其实对早期时期的这种精致进行了一点调侃。“松树间的晚风叹息”这一切都非常诗意。但与此同时，他把它颠覆了过来，并说：看，日本在这个时代，我们玩得很开心。这有点下流，我们并不是完全为自己感到骄傲，但在经历了很长一段时间的战争之后，我们正在享受和平带来的好处。
having all sorts of fun, getting into all sorts of trouble along the way. And it's a lovely way to be, as it were, given a tour of Japan in the 17th century. He's kind of Casanova figure, would you say? Yeah, I think absolutely. Yeah. So he, just to give you a little quote from one of his, from part of this book, this is a book called The Life of an Amorous Man, which tells you most of what you slipped into the tub. She was quite sure that no one was about. If there should be any sound at all, it could be nothing but the sigh of evening breezes among the nearby pines. So thinking, at any rate, she started to rub herself vigorously with rice bran soap and a towel. The water was pleasantly hot. She took particular relish in removing the dirt from
所以这就是所谓的浮世（floating world）的浪漫，不是吗？“浮世”就是这个概念。那么你能解释一下“浮世”是什么意思吗？因为有些人会熟悉这个词，是因为石黑一雄（Ishiguro）的小说，书名叫《浮世画家》（The Artist of the Floating World），对吧？所以，这个词，“浮世”（ukiyo），最初是一个佛教术语。指的是存在转瞬即逝的特质，以及它是如何充满悲伤和哀愁的，人们不应该执着于此。
the lower parts of her body. Suddenly, as though by instinct, she looked up and there on the tiled roof of the tea house next door, she saw the crouching figure of the boy, Yonosuke, levelling a long spyglass at her. So this is him from very early on in his life, but it gives you a sense of what his interests are. But also I think in you can, if we think back to that really refined period of Murasaki, what Ihara does in his work is he slightly plays on that refinement from this earlier period. You know, the sigh of the evening breeze is among the nearby pines is all very poetical. But then at the same time, he turns it on his head and says, look, Japan in this era, we're having lots of fun. It's a little bit dirty and we're not entirely proud of ourselves, but we're enjoying the benefits of peace, basically, after a very long time of war.
但在个时代，它开始意味着完全不同的东西，特别是对东京（当时称为江户），以及大阪和京都而言。这些都是这样的世界：如果你是一个手里有点钱的商人，你就可以参与各种各样的娱乐活动——从歌舞伎到茶馆、艺伎，再到购买这些美丽的木版画，我们很多人大概——这些版画有助于我们在脑海中呈现——如果有人见过那些版画的话，它们有助于我们把我们在这里谈论的时代视觉化。
So this is the romance of the kind of floating world, isn't it? The floating world is the idea. So can you explain about what the floating world means? Because some people will be familiar with that because of Ishiguro's novel, which is called The Artist of the Floating World, isn't it? So yeah, that word, floating world, or ukiyo in Japanese, it was originally a Buddhist term. So talking about the fleeting quality of existence and how it was full of sadness and pathos and one shouldn't get attached.
所以它要有趣得多，这是日本的一个黄金时代，这个词就代表了这一点。江户（Kazido），也就是现在的东京，你刚才说在1700年可能是世界上最大的城市，拥有百万居民。而且显然充满了各种好玩的事情。所以你提到了歌舞伎——那么歌舞伎是如何开始的呢？作为一种滑稽短剧，然后它演变成了一个日益复杂的戏剧传统？没错，所以它最初或多或少是一种宣传……妓女的方式，这样她们就可以四处跳舞。
But it comes to mean something completely different in this era, particularly Tokyo, or Edo as it was called then, alongside Osaka and Kyoto. These are worlds where if you're a merchant with a little bit of money, you can get involved in all sorts of pleasures from kabuki to the tea houses to geisha to buying these beautiful woodblock prints, which a lot of us probably, it helps us to visualize, if anyone's seen those prints, which a lot of us probably, it helps us to visualize, if anyone's seen those prints, the era that we're talking about here.
所以那是个滑稽短剧。所以汤姆·霍兰，那不过是个滑稽短剧。是的，正好。我想喜剧元素并不是最突出的。更重要的是你是否想把其中一个人带回家。汤姆曾经跟我谈论过高雅艺术，结果发现他谈论的是你在电话亭里经常看到的那种卡片。
So it's much more fun and it's sort of a golden age for Japan that that word denotes. Kazido, which becomes Tokyo, you said perhaps the largest city in the world in 1700, a million inhabitants. And just obviously teeming with fun things to do. So you mentioned kabuki so kabuki begins what as kind of skits and then it becomes this increasingly sophisticated theatrical tradition that's right so it begins more or less as a as a way of advertising uh prostitutes so they can dance around.
主导。大概就是那个水平吧，是的，对于早期的歌舞伎来说。绝对是的，是的。但是，我的意思是，它最后没有女性参与了，对吧？因为有一个令人难以置信的著名传统，即由男性扮演女性角色。是“女形”（Onagata）吗？是的，没错，女子的风格。
So that's a skit. So Tom Holland, that is just merely a skit. Yes, exactly. I think the comedy element is not to the fore there. It's more whether you might like to take one of these people home. Tom once was just telling me about high art, and it turned out he was talking about those cards that you used to see in phone boxes.
所以那是个小品。所以汤姆·赫兰德，那纯粹只是个小品。是的，完全正确。我觉得喜剧元素在那里并不突出。更主要的是看你是否想把这些人带回家。汤姆曾经跟我谈论高雅艺术，结果发现他谈论的是以前在电话亭里常见的那种卡片。
Dominate. That's probably about the level, yes, for early Kabuki. Absolutely, yeah. But, I mean, it ends up without women, doesn't it? Because there's this incredibly famous tradition of men playing the roles of women. Was it onagata? Yes, yeah, exactly, the woman's style.
主导。对于早期的歌舞伎来说，这大概就是那个水平吧，是的。绝对是，是的。但是，我的意思是，最后没有了女性，对吧？因为有一个极其著名的传统，就是由男人扮演女性的角色。是女形吗？是的，是的，完全正确，女人的风格。
That's partly because of the kind of continued worries about prostitution on the side. But then, you know, men want to take men home as well, so it doesn't make a terrible amount of difference, but it does have that effect on Kabuki. It gives it that quality. I remember the first summer I lived in London, there was a big festival of Japan and they had Kabuki. Am I remembering right? That if there are kind of famous dynasties of actors and you shout out their name when they do something particularly amazing so it be like kind of saying red grave or fox costner well he hasn't got a he hasn't got a dynasty i think that's right you've got people like um ichikawa danjuro that they are probably japan's
这部分是因为人们对旁边卖淫现象的持续担忧。不过话说回来，男人们也想带男人们回家，所以这其实没太大区别，但它确实对歌舞伎产生了这种影响。它赋予了歌舞伎那种特质。我还记得我住在伦敦的第一个夏天，当时有一个盛大的日本节，里面有歌舞伎表演。我没记错吧？就是如果某种演员世家非常有名，当他们做出特别惊艳的动作时，你可以大声喊出他们的名字，这有点像喊出格雷夫斯或福克斯·科斯特纳的名字——好吧，他可没有什么世家。我觉得这没错，你们有像市川团十郎这样的人，他们可能就是日本的
first celebrities because not only would you go and see them but you might get a woodblock print of their um face or a particular famous scene from a play with them in it and those woodblock prints i mean now if you found an original one be worth a good deal of money in those days it's the price of a snack so yeah it's it's properly uh it's properly celebrity time i think in the 17th century in japan okay we've gone through three of your choices, Chris. We've got three more to do after the break, but as we go into the break, I want to ask Tom a question that is from one of Ihara's books. And Tom, you can have the break to think about your answer. Maybe Chris can give his answer as well. Maybe he won't want to. The question is this, which is to be preferred,
第一批名人，因为你不仅会去看他们演出，还可能会买到一张描绘他们面部或剧中某个著名场景的木版画。现在如果你能找到一张原版木版画，那可值不少钱，但在当年，那也就只是一份小吃的价格。所以，我认为在17世纪的日本，这确实是名副其实的名人时代了。好了，克里斯，你的三个选择我们已经介绍完了。中场休息后还有三个要讲，但在进入中场休息之际，我想问汤姆一个问题，这个问题来自井原西鹤的一本书。汤姆，你可以趁中场休息的时候想想答案。也许克里斯也可以给出他的答案。也许他不想。问题是这样的：以下哪种情况更让人倾向于选择
lying rejected next to a courtesan or conversing intimately with a kabuki boy who is suffering from haemorrhoids? Come back after the break and Tom Holland will be telling us his answer. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes,
躺在交际花旁边惨遭冷落，还是与一个患有痔疮的歌舞伎少年亲密交谈？休息回来后，汤姆·霍兰德将告诉我们他的答案。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐就是一切》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、少许八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告节目、独家番外，
and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. And probably like me, you're waiting on tenterhooks to find out tom holland's answer would he rather lie rejected next to a courtesan or converse intimately with a kabuki boy who is suffering from hemorrhoids tom your answer please the latter of course because i don't care if he's got hemorrhoids but i don't want to be rejected okay there you go is that the
以及提前购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史就是一切》。大家可能和我一样，正翘首以盼地等待着汤姆·霍兰德的答案：他是愿意躺在交际花旁边被冷落，还是愿意和一个患有痔疮的歌舞伎少年亲密交谈？汤姆，请说出你的答案。当然是后者，因为我才不在乎他有没有痔疮，但我可不想被冷落。好吧，就是这样。这是
right answer chris absolutely yes yeah very good Yeah, very good. Well done, Tom. So now we know where you stand. Certainly not Sid. Oh, yes. Okay, so Chris, give us please your fourth person for Japanese history. So I think the fourth one would be the so-called father of Japanese capitalism, Shibusawa Eichi. And he's around for roughly the second half of the 19th century and the early part of the 20th. This is the point during his life where Japan is more or less forced actually to reopen to the West treaties slightly along the lines of those
正确的答案吗，克里斯？绝对是的，没错，很好。没错，很好，干得漂亮，汤姆。现在我们知道你的立场了。当然不是指西德。噢，是的。好吧，克里斯，请给我们讲讲你的第四位日本历史人物。我认为第四位是所谓的“日本资本主义之父”涩泽荣一。他大致活跃于19世纪下半叶到20世纪初。正是在他生活的这个时期，日本或多或少被迫向西方重新开放，这些条约有点类似于
with China after the Opium War, if you've just come out of a China program, which are not at all to Japan's benefit, but forced on them really, kind of gunboat diplomacy by the Americans, British, French, Russians, and others. And he's interesting because he covers this period after these treaties, which are 1850s into the early 1860s, where Japan is acutely aware of its vulnerability in the world. And it's asking, how can it possibly catch up? How can it defend itself? How can it avoid the fate of China, you know, which just next door is being essentially carved up by some of the big world powers. And he also, he lives through probably the key event in Japanese history in the 19th century, which is the Meiji Restoration. That is 1868, and that is when the
鸦片战争后与中国签订的条约——如果你刚听完一档关于中国的节目的话——这些条约对日本毫无益处，实际上是美国、英国、法国、俄国等国通过炮舰外交强加给日本的。他之所以有趣，是因为他经历了这些条约签订之后的时期，即19世纪50年代到60年代初，当时日本对自己在世界上所处的脆弱地位有着清醒的认识。它在质问：日本究竟怎么才能迎头赶上？它如何保卫自己？它如何才能避免中国那样的命运——要知道，近邻中国当时正被几个世界大国瓜分。而且他还经历了19世纪日本历史上最关键的事件，即明治维新。那是1868年，
Tokugawa shogunate comes to an end, and the restoration is the restoration of the rule of the emperor. Meiji is the name of the emperor who presides over this. Am I right that that's the key pivot, really, for modern Japanese history? I think so, yeah. There are these 10, 15 extraordinary bloody years after the Americans arrived and forced the Japanese to open up in the really, for modern Japanese history? I think so, yeah. There are these sort of 10, 15 extraordinary bloody years after the Americans arrived and forced the Japanese to open up in the mid-1850s, where young samurai in particular, and Shibusawa is probably a good example of that, they are shocked by American technology, the weapons technology, the steamships, and they think that the elder generation of samurai in Japan simply are irresponsible.
德川幕府走到了尽头，而维新指的是天皇统治的恢复。明治是主导这一进程的天皇的名字。我没记错吧？这确实是日本现代史的关键转折点？我想是的。在外国人抵达并迫使日本在真正意义上对现代日本历史开放之后，大约有10年到15年极其血腥的时期。我想是的，没错。在美国人抵达并迫使日本在19世纪50年代中期开放之后，有大约10到15年非常血腥的时期，特别是年轻的武士——涩泽荣一或许就是一个很好的例子——他们对美国的科技、武器技术以及轮船感到震惊，他们认为日本老一辈的武士简直是不负责任。
They don't really know how to put the country on a strong footing anymore. And it gets to the point 1867-1868 where you have a brief civil war in Japan and the Tokugawa lose and you have this new younger generation of victorious samurai who go on to become almost like the equivalent of the founding fathers in the US, I think. Just on him. So he's called the, what is he called? The John Pierpoint Morgan, is it? Of Japan by the Washington Herald or something. Yeah, they love to compare him. You call him the father of Japanese capitalism. Yes. But I suppose he's a great person to ask. If you take him out of the story, is Japanese history any different? So is he the embodiment of something or is he genuinely a a sort of motor of change if you know what I mean
他们根本不知道如何让国家重新走上强盛的轨道。到了1867至1868年，日本爆发了一场短暂的内战，德川幕府战败，随后出现了一代新的、更年轻的胜利武士，我认为他们几乎成了美国“国父”级别的存在。就说这个人吧。他被称为，他被称为叫什么来着？《华盛顿先驱报》之类的报纸称他为日本的约翰·皮庞·摩根，对吗？是的，人们很喜欢拿他作比较。你称他为日本资本主义之父。是的。但我猜他是一个很好的人选：如果你把他从历史中拿掉，日本历史会有所不同吗？所以，他究竟是某种事物的化身，还是说，如果你懂我的意思的话，他确实是某种变革的推动者？
it's a good question I think he's much more the embodiment because he's one of the first people to to go for a joint stock company to get that idea across to people to generate the trust where complete strangers might give you some cash on the hope that, you know, your factory might make it. Because he's travelled to Europe, hasn't he? He's been to France, he's been to Britain. Yes. He's had tea with Queen Victoria. He goes in the train of a shogun. Yes, absolutely. He's one of a generation who do these amazing tours. Some of them go literally all the way around the world, fact-finding, basically, finding out what makes these great powers tick in terms of industry weapons culture and what japan can do i think if shibasawa hadn't been around then probably someone
这是个好问题。我认为他更多的是一种化身，因为他是最早推行股份制公司、将这种理念传递给人们并建立信任的人之一，在这种信任下，素不相识的陌生人可能会把现金交给你，只希望你的工厂能成功。因为他去过欧洲，对吧？他去过法国，去过英国。是的。他曾与维多利亚女王喝过茶。他是跟随幕府将军的随行人员出访的。没错，绝对是的。他是进行这些惊人环球旅行的一代人中的一员。他们中的一些人几乎环游了整个世界，进行实地考察，基本上是为了弄清楚这些工业、武器和文化大国的运作机制，以及日本能做些什么。我认为，如果没有涩泽荣一在身边，可能也会有其他人
else would have come up with the idea of um imitating or adapting the joint stock company idea so he's much more an embodiment of an era um i think than he is a motor i'm not sure there's anyone in the book who could credibly call a motor in that kind of great man tradition. You say he becomes personally involved in 500 companies. He helps to set up a hundred of them. One of them is Sapporo, the beer, which I'm sure people will be familiar with. He helps to form the Tokyo Electric Light Company, which is Japan's first electricity company. He establishes Nippon Railway. So, I mean, he's absolutely Mr. Capitalism. And yet, at the same time, he is a samurai. I mean, as a young man, he studies fencing, he serves a shogun. I mean, he lives to a fabulous age. He dies in 1931. Is he fusing those samurai traditions
想出模仿或改造股份公司理念的主意，所以我认为他更多的是一个时代的化身，而不是一个推动者。我不确定书中是否有人能在那种伟人传统的意义上被真正称为推动者。你说他个人参与了500家公司的创立，他帮助创立了其中的100家。其中一家就是札幌啤酒，大家一定都很熟悉。他还帮助组建了东京电灯公司，这是日本第一家电力公司。他创立了日本铁道。所以，我的意思是，他绝对是资本主义先生。然而与此同时，他却是一个武士。我的意思是，年轻时他练习剑术，效忠将军。我的意思是，他活到了令人惊叹的高龄，于1931年去世。他是在将这些武士精神
with Western capitalism? Are they coexisting? Is he suppressing the samurai within him to become a capitalist? What's the kind of the balance within him, do you think? It's a tricky one. And there's a bigger question there about how Japan tries to adapt to capitalism. So the claim that someone like Shibusawa would make is that, and this is the claim that lots of others are making in Japan in the era, is that we're not just going to simply copy a Western model. We're going to do it our way. And what that means for him is capitalism with an infusion of Confucian principles. So the joint stock company isn't simply about people taking a punt and making some money. It's about the virtue of cooperation. And in his factories as well, he says, look, you know, between workers
与西方资本主义相融合吗？它们是共存的吗？他是在压抑体内的武士精神来成为一个资本主义者吗？你认为他内心深处的平衡是怎样的？这是一个棘手的问题。这里还有一个更大的问题，那就是日本如何试图适应资本主义。像涩泽荣一这样的人会宣称——这也是当时日本许多其他人所宣称的——我们不只是简单地照搬西方模式。我们要走自己的路。对他来说，这意味着将儒家原则融入资本主义之中。因此，股份公司不仅仅是人们碰运气赚点钱的事，它关乎合作的美德。而且在工厂里他也说，你看，无论是工人和
and management, again, the ethics should be cooperation. Sometimes man and woman is the metaphor. Sometimes it's, you know, parents and children. Japan has to be built on that basis because if you don't, then you get the slums of London or Liverpool or something like that. So he would claim and others would claim that there is a downside to Western modernity. And because they've been there first, we can learn and do it differently. So it's something obviously that happens in a key moment in his lifetime is the war with Russia. Yes. In the early years of the 20th century.
管理层之间，其道德准则也应该是合作。有时男人和女人是这种隐喻，有时是父母和孩子。日本必须建立在这样的基础之上，否则你就会得到伦敦或利物浦那样的贫民窟。因此，他和许多人会宣称，西方现代性是有负面影响的。正因为他们走在了前面，我们才可以吸取教训并用不同的方式去做。所以，这显然发生在他生命中的一个关键时刻，那就是日俄战争。是的。在20世纪初。
And then by the time he dies, he dies in what, 1931, I think it is? Yes. So by that point, Japan is already becoming ever more entangled on the kind of Asian mainland, isn't it? So to what extent is he implicated, since he is the embodiment of Japanese capitalism? Yeah. To what extent is he, by the time of his death, implicated in what we would now describe, I guess, as Japanese imperialism in East Asia? A little bit, because he makes some money in places like Korea,
然后到他去世时，他死于1931年左右吧？是的。所以在那个时候，日本已经越来越深地卷入亚洲大陆了，不是吗？那么，既然他是日本资本主义的化身，他在多大程度上也卷入了这一切？是的。到他去世时，他在多大程度上卷入了我们现在大概会称之为日本在东亚的帝国主义行径？有一点，因为他在朝鲜等地赚了一些钱，
after Japan's annexation of Korea in 1909 to 10. So he's certainly happy to make the most of those sorts of opportunities. I think the mentality in Japan in this time is, well, look at what any great power does in the world. It gets itself an empire for its own benefit and for the purpose of spreading so-called civilization. And at the same time, if Japan doesn't do it, especially in its backyard, then it's asking for trouble. I think there's that sense of Japan being a prisoner of geography. If you imagine the archipelago running down just off the coast of China and then Korea, you can't risk the European power or the Americans having effective, or the Russians, having effective control of, for example, the Korean peninsula, because it's a few
在1909到1910年日本吞并朝鲜之后。所以他当然乐于利用这类机会。我认为当时日本的心态是：看看世界上任何一个大国都在做什么，它为了自身的利益和传播所谓文明的目的而为自己夺取一个帝国。与此同时，如果日本不这样做，尤其是在自己的后院，那它就是在自找麻烦。我觉得有一种日本是地理囚徒的感觉。如果你想象一下那个从中国和朝鲜海岸延伸出来的群岛，你就不能冒险让欧洲列强、美国或俄国对朝鲜半岛等地区进行有效的控制，因为这里距离你自己的海岸
short miles off your own coast. So that's the kind of rationale that goes along. And people actually want Japan to be strong, want Japan to be a leader in Asia. And I think they're fairly comfortable with the idea of making some money on the side. It's always sort of puzzled me that Japan is so successful in this period. You know, they've had the Meiji Restoration, They've embraced capitalism. They are the sort of poster boys for Asian modernity, I suppose. And yet at the same time, there is that increasing paranoia too strong, a sense of being embattled and hemmed in and all of that sort of stuff, when in a way you could say they should be luxuriating in their success. Yeah, I think it's often a claim that gets made in Japan, probably from the 1868 moment
只有短短的几英里。这就是背后的逻辑。人们其实希望日本强大，希望日本成为亚洲的领导者。而且我认为他们对于顺便赚点钱这种事感到挺坦然的。我一直有点困惑的是，日本在这段时期是如此成功。你知道，他们经历了明治维新，拥抱了资本主义，我想他们可以说是亚洲现代性的海报男孩。然而与此同时，那种日益加深的偏执、一种强烈的受围困和受挤压的感觉却挥之不去，而按理说，他们在某种程度上本该沉浸在成功的喜悦中。是的，我认为这是日本经常发出的一种呼声，大概从1868年那一刻
onwards all the way through to 1945, is that Japan is in danger. Japan is in some kind of peril from world powers that don't wish it well. There's that claim in the end of being encircled. You can run right the way around the clock, what, anti-clock wise. You've got the Russians, you've got the Chinese, you've got the British and the Dutch, and then you've got the Americans, you know, to the east. So that's often a claim that gets made. And it's hard to differentiate between that being pure ideology and that being a statement of truth, I suppose. But famously, so you mentioned Port Arthur and Japan is the first Asian power to defeat a European power, i.e. Russia. Yes.
一直持续到1945年，即日本处于危险之中。日本面临着来自不怀好意的世界大国的某种危险。最终有一种被包围的论调。你可以按逆时针方向绕上一圈。你有俄国人，你有中国人，你有英国人和荷兰人，然后东边还有美国人。所以这经常是一种被提出的论调。我想，很难区分这究竟是纯粹的意识形态，还是对真相的陈述。但正如人们所知，你提到了旅顺口，日本是第一个击败欧洲列强（即俄国）的亚洲强国。是的。
In a war. And you have a brilliant chapter kind of illustrating the ambivalences and tensions within Japan during this period. And this is a poet called Yasano Akiko. And she is the youngest brother, isn't it, who's fighting? He's been stationed to Port Arthur. She writes a famous poem that is essentially pacifist. Brother, do not give your life. His majesty, the emperor goes not himself into the battle. Could he with such deeply noble heart think it an honor for men to spill one another's blood and die like beasts? And so this makes her both famous and notorious. Famous for the delicacy
在一场战争中。你有一个出色的章节，生动地展现了日本在这个时期的矛盾心理和紧张情绪。这是一个名叫与谢野晶子的女诗人。参军的是她的幼弟，对吧？他被派驻到了旅顺。她写了一首著名的诗，本质上是反战的。弟弟啊，不要牺牲你的生命。天皇陛下本人并不亲赴战场。难道他能凭着如此深厚高尚的心灵，认为男人自相残杀、像野兽一样死去是一种荣誉吗？这让她既出名又声名狼藉。出名是因为她
with which she articulates her love for her brother and her anxiety about the war that's going on, and notorious because obviously she is offending monarchists and nationalists. But the parabola of her life is a really remarkable one. So you just tell us a bit about her and where she goes from that kind of early pacifism. Absolutely. So I think she is, in the beginning, what you might call a quintessential cosmopolitan liberal. So she wants to reform women's status in society. Women are very much second class citizens in the early 20th century in Japan. She writes some very, what you might call some rather risque poetry early on, give you a very quick bit of that just to give people a flavour.
细腻地表达了对弟弟的爱以及对正进行着的战争的焦虑，而声名狼藉则是因为她显然冒犯了君主主义者和民族主义者。但她一生的发展轨迹确实非常引人注目。所以，请给我们讲讲她，以及她如何从那种早期的反战主义走向别处。当然。我认为她一开始是个典型的世界主义自由主义者。她希望改革女性在社会中的地位。在20世纪初的日本，女性很大程度上是二等公民。她早期写了一些相当——你可以称之为——有些出格的诗，我很快读一小段给各位听听，好让大家体会一下。
It's in the Tanka style, which is a very, these very, very short verses. So one of them would be in my bath, submerged like some graceful lily at the bottom of a spring. How beautiful this body of 20 summers. So she's got a series called Tangled Hair of poems, very much along those lines, and lots of the male critics regard it as sort of verging on pornography, or I think one calls it the precocious prattle of a young girl. So she's not terribly well received in some circles, but she really stakes her claim, as I say, to be a cosmopolitan figure interested in women's rights, interested in education and producing some really cutting edge poetry. And then, as you say, when this war comes up with Russia, she expresses a feeling in
这是短歌风格，非常非常短的诗句。其中一首是这样的：在我的浴缸里，如同泉底优雅的百合般潜藏。二十岁青春的躯体是多么美丽。她有一系列名为《乱发》的诗集，基本都是这种风格，许多男评论家认为这近乎色情，我想其中一人称之为“小女孩的早熟胡言乱语”。所以在某些圈子里，她并不是很受欢迎，但正如我所说，她确实确立了自己作为一位世界主义人物的地位，她关注女性权利，关注教育，并创作了一些非常前卫的诗歌。然后，正如你所说，当这场与俄国的战争爆发时，她表达了日本的一种情绪，
Japan, which I think is quite broad, which is, do we need this war? You know, 10 years before Japan had fought China and there was a case for that war, people would say the case for a war with Russia was a little bit more difficult to make. And although it's very hard in public to object to it, the worst thing you could be was a pacifist, or the worst thing you could be was probably a Christian socialist pacifist. And there were some of those. Dominic would agree with that. Thanks. Well, I'm not going to disagree with you. But she has this extraordinary trajectory, doesn't she? So is she a feminist?
我认为这种情绪相当普遍，那就是：我们真的需要这场战争吗？10年前日本曾与中国打过仗，那场战争还有点理由，而人们会说，与俄国开战的理由就更难成立了。尽管在公开场合反对它是很难的，最糟糕的事情莫过于做一个和平主义者，或者最糟糕的事情莫过于做一个基督教社会主义和平主义者。当时确实有一些这样的人。多米尼克会同意这一点的。谢谢。好吧，我可不会反驳你。但她有着非凡的心路历程，不是吗？所以她是一个女权主义者吗？
Would it be fair? Or is that imposing a Western label onto her? No, no. I think a lot of the women of her era would be happy to be called that. And they drew a certain amount of inspiration from Western feminism. They're trying to get past, I suppose, what one of them, probably the most famous feminist of the era, Hiratsuka Raicho, talks about women's role in Japan
这样说公平吗？还是说这是把一个西不西、中不中的西方标签强加在她身上？不，不。我认为她那个时代的许多女性会很高兴被称为女权主义者。她们从西方女权主义中汲取了一定程度的灵感。我想，她们试图超越其中一人——大概是那个时代最著名的女权主义者平冢雷鸟——所说的女性在日本的角色，即
as being slavery during the daytime and prostitution at night. So their social position, their constitutional position, they're kept out of politics for most of this era. So that's really, I think, how she would define herself. But competing with that part of her, for most of this era. So that's really, I think, how she would define herself. But competing with that part of her as you get into the late 1920s and early 1930s,
白天是奴隶，夜晚是妓女。所以她们的社会地位、宪法地位，在这一时期的绝大部分时间里都被排挤在政治之外。所以，我想这确实是她会如何定义自己的方式。但与她的这一面竞争的是，随着进入20世纪20年代末和30年代初，
so as things start to hot up for Japan in East Asia, she starts to change her view. I suppose in the chapter I write on her, one of the potential turning points is when she goes to um the mainland in 1928 and does this short tour so at this point and this may have come up perhaps in your china conversation um the south manchurian railway which is this uh railway line and a kind of corridor of land um along with it which the japanese have possession of and they're exploiting for you know minerals and whatnot and she goes across there. And like a lot of Japanese intellectuals, I think in the modern era,
随着日本在东亚的局势开始升温，她的观点开始发生变化。我想我在写她的那一章时，潜在的转折点之一是她在1928年去大陆进行了一次短途旅行。当时——这或许在你们关于中国的讨论中提到过——南满铁路，这是一条铁路以及沿线的一条狭长地带，日本占领了这里，并一直在利用它（开采矿产等）——她去到了那里。像许多日本知识分子一样，我想在现代，
to go to China is on the one hand to see Japan's past because lots of that artistic imagery, poetical imagery comes from there. And on the other, it's to reflect on Japan's vulnerability now in the world. So she comes home after this trip. And as Japan becomes steadily, you know, in the early 1930s, something of an international pariah, her poetry takes this extraordinary right-wing turn, which a lot of her biographers don't really know what to do with,
去中国一方面是为了看日本的过去，因为很多那种艺术意象、诗意意象都源自那里。另一方面，这也是为了反思日本当今在世界上的脆弱地位。所以她这次旅行回家后，随着日本在20世纪30年代逐渐变成了某种国际弃儿，她的诗歌发生了这种非凡的右翼转向，这让她的许多传记作家感到无所适从，
because it's so much against the Yosano Akiko that they'd known before. I'll give you a few lines of that if you like, if we've got time. Yeah, go for it. Yeah. So even the title of one of these poems, rosy-cheeked death, I think gives you a sense of where it might be going. But very briefly, to the west of the river, she writes,
因为它与他们以前认识的与谢野晶子大相径庭。如果你愿意的话，如果有时间的话，我可以给你读几行这样的诗。好的，来吧。好的。所以，甚至其中一首诗的标题——《面颊绯红的死亡》——我想就能让你大致感受到它可能的发展方向。但简而言之，在河西岸，她写道：
we see something in the trenches. Approaching, we find enemy corpses. Enemy corpses lying one upon the other. And she goes through talking about these beautiful young soldiers who ought to be married at this point, but instead they've been, basically, as she sees it, pushed into service by corrupt Chinese leaders. And yet they blame what she calls their good neighbour, Japan.
我们看到战壕里有些东西。走近一看，发现是敌人的尸体。敌人的尸体一具叠着一具。她接着谈到这些本该结婚的美丽年轻士兵，但相反，他们基本上被她眼中腐败的中国领导人推上了战场。然而他们却指责他们所谓的友好邻邦日本。
So it's this incredible turn into really polemical poetry. I have to say that coming from Rana's episode, where we looked at Manchuria and the start of the war and Shanghai and Nanjing and all that kind of thing, absolutely through Chinese eyes, that seeing it through her eyes is really quite shocking. What does she feel? She feels that China is decadent, corrupt, and falling to pieces, that Japan has offered the hand of friendship, and that the Chinese have spurned it.
所以这是一个令人难以置信的转向，变成了充满论辩色彩的诗歌。我必须说，从兰娜的节目（我们审视了满洲国、战争的起点、上海、南京以及所有这一切，完全是通过中国人的眼睛来看的）转过来，通过她的眼睛来看这件事，确实相当令人震惊。她有什么感受？她觉得中国是颓废的、腐败的、四分五裂的，日本已经伸出了友谊之手，而中国人却不屑一顾。
And therefore, basically, they deserve what they get. Yes, I might slightly quibble with maybe just the last bit. Okay, I'm being harsh on her. But I think her view of China, and that's the view of many people in Japan at this point, that Japan is essentially a good actor in the world, but that it's being pushed around by these extraordinary self-righteous Western powers in particular. I mean, something like the League of Nations is seen in Japan as being a bunch of people who won the First World War, the Great War, and were not prepared to give something like a racial equality clause to the Japanese. And Japanese who go to America in the early 20th century is subject to extraordinary racism there.
因此，基本上，他们是自作自受。是的，对于最后一点，我可能要稍微吹毛求疵一下。好吧，我对她太苛刻了。但我认为她对中国的看法——这也是当时日本许多人的看法——是日本本质上是世界上的一个善良行动者，但它一直被这些极其自以为是的西方列强（尤其是西方列强）推来搡去。我的意思是，像国际联盟这样的组织在日本被视为一群赢得第一次世界大战（即大战）的人，却准备不给日本人一个诸如种族平等条款之类的东西。20世纪初去美国的日本人也遭受了非凡的种族主义对待。
So hypocrisy is a big theme for the Japanese when they think about the West. And I think that's part of Yosun Akiko's outlook as well. But she's, I mean, there's something of the way that Russians justify the invasion of Ukraine about some of her poetry. So she writes, this is about the Japanese in Shanghai, knowing their cause to be just, our forces attack through sufferings a hundredfold. So the emphasis is all on Japanese suffering and the justice of the cause. There's nothing about what happens to the Chinese. Absolutely. And there's that attempt
因此，虚伪是日本人在思考西方时的一个大主题。我想这也是与谢野晶子世界观的一部分。但她的某些诗歌，有那么一点俄罗斯人为入侵乌克兰辩护的味道。所以她写道——这是关于日本在上海的——深知我们的正义之师，历经百倍磨难发起进攻。因此，重点完全在于日本人的苦难和正义性。对于中国人的遭遇，只字不提。绝对是的。而且在
in that bit of the poem that i was quoting to separate out innocent ordinary chinese from their um terrible dishonest and anti-japanese leadership that said for some in japan there is a straightforward racism where the chinese and the koreans are basically lesser beings and so it's more consumable than you might otherwise imagine to do what you need to do to them i suppose uh the so-called rape of nanjing would be the classic example um of that kind of behavior by japanese troops who were brought up on that way of thinking and she dies in 1942 she's had a stroke hasn't she does she by the time that she dies is there an element of doubt um so pearl
我刚刚引用的那段诗中，有一种企图，即将无辜的普通中国人和他们可怕、不诚实、反日本的领导阶层区分开来。话虽如此，对于日本的一些人来说，存在着一种赤裸裸的种族主义，即中国人和朝鲜人基本上是低人一等的存在，因此，对他们做你需要做的事，比你想象的要更容易接受。我想，所谓的“南京大屠杀”就是接受这种思想熏陶的日本军队这种行为的经典例子。她于1942年去世，中风了，对吗？在她去世时，有没有一丝怀疑——所以珍珠
harbor has happened america's entered the war although at that point i suppose there's no sense yet of the japanese being pushed back they're still expanding does she have any hint of doubt well she she dies as you say pretty much one of the high points of that conflict for the japanese because they're pushing back the enemy on all sorts of fronts but she has this lovely last line in one of her poems. It is a time for falling tears as we enter the bitter cold
珍珠港事件发生了，美国参战了，尽管在那时，我想还没有人感觉到日军正在被击退，他们仍在扩张。她有任何一丝怀疑吗？嗯，她正如你所说的那样去世了，那时几乎是日本在这场冲突中的最高点之一，因为他们在各个战线上都在将敌人逼退。但她在她的一首诗中留下了这样一句优美的遗言：这是落泪的时刻，当我们步入严寒
of the 12th lunar month. So some people would read that as her thinking, actually, we've at last bitten off more than we can chew here. And it's very unpredictable from here. Falling tears is putting it mildly. So Japan suffers.
港事件已经发生，美国已经参战，尽管当时我想还没有任何日本被打退的迹象，他们仍在扩张——她有任何怀疑的迹象吗？嗯，正如你所说，她去世时正值那场冲突对日本人来说相当高潮的时期，因为他们在各个战线上都在将敌人逼退。但她的其中一首诗里有这样一句美妙的末尾行。这是进入12月农历苦寒时节、令人落泪的时刻。所以有些人会将其解读为她其实在想：实际上，我们这次终于咬下了嚼不烂的东西，从这以后局势就非常不可预测了。落泪说得还是轻的。所以日本遭受了——
I mean, Japan inflicts terrible suffering, but suffers terribly in the war. Atom bombs, of course, we know, but the firebombing of Tokyo causes even more deaths, is that right, than the atom bombs? So Japan kind of emerges a broken society under American tutelage, and yet emerges in the post-war years, becomes an incredible success story. Richest country in the world by the 90s, is it? Isn't the whole of the Imperial Palace in Tokyo valued at being more than California or something? Ah, right, this famous land bubble.
我的意思是，日本带来了可怕的苦难，但在战争中也遭受了可怕的苦难。原子弹，当然，我们都知道，但东京的大轰炸造成的死亡人数甚至比原子弹还要多，是这样吗？所以日本作为一个破碎的社会在美国的管辖下崛起，然而在战后几年里崛起，成为了一个不可思议的成功故事。到90年代成了世界上最富有的国家，对吧？东京皇居的整体价值难道不比整个加利福尼亚还高吗？啊，对了，这个著名的土地泡沫。
Is that not true? No, no, it's true. It's a story that's always told. I think that's a fair estimation. It doesn't last very long because there's a horrific crash after that. But it speaks to the power of the Japanese economy. Yes. And so it becomes economically incredibly successful, but it also becomes culturally very, very successful. I guess that perhaps the most famous cultural export is manga. And the man you've chosen as your final, the last of the six Japanese lives, is Tezuka Osamu, the god of manga, who authored 150,000 pages of manga. So tell us about him and why you've chosen him. So I think he's important because he shows the link with the war for Japan's manga and anime.
这不是真的吗？不，不，这是真的。这是一个经常被人讲述的故事。我认为这是一个合理的估算。它并没有持续太久，因为在那之后发生了一次可怕的崩溃。但这说明了日本经济的力量。是的。所以它在经济上变得不可思议地成功，但在文化上也变得非常非常成功。我想，也许最著名的文化出口就是漫画。而你选为最后一位、六个日本人生平中最后一位的人物，是“漫画之神”手冢治虫，他创作了15万页的漫画。所以给我们讲讲他，以及你为什么选择他。我认为他很重要，因为他展现了日本漫画和动画与战争的联系。
Now, one of the things that people find distinctive, I think, about Japanese manga and anime is that there's a blending of the world of children with the world of adults. You know, anyone who's seen any of the productions by Studio Ghibli, for example, Grave of the Fireflies, I would recommend Totoro as well, recently on at the Barbican as a stage play. One of the things that really draws people in is that, yeah, the world of children and the world of adults is mixed together. And it's people like Tezuka Osamu who achieve that because they've been through the war, you know, he's watched burned bodies floating down the river in Osaka. And he thinks, how on earth did we get ourselves to that point? And one of the answers is that people were deeply led astray by a corrupt adult world. And so what they want to do when they produce children's entertainment is help children to wise up a little bit, to have some sense of what the adult world is like, even while they're young,
现在，人们认为日本漫画和动画独特的一点，我认为是儿童世界与成人世界的融合。你知道，任何看过吉卜力工作室作品的人，比如《萤火虫之墓》，我还要推荐《龙猫》，最近作为舞台剧在巴比肯艺术中心上演。真正吸引人们的一点是，儿童世界和成人世界交织在了一起。正是手冢治虫这样的人实现了这一点，因为他们经历过战争，你看，他看过烧焦的尸体漂浮在大阪的河面上。他在想：我们究竟是怎么走到这一步的？其中一个答案是，人们被一个腐败的成人世界引入了歧途。因此，当他们制作儿童娱乐节目时，他们想做的是帮助孩子们稍微变得聪明一点，对成人世界有一个认识，即使在他们年轻的时候，
to appreciate it and not be drawn in by it or fooled by it in adult life. So he gives that quality to Japanese manga and anime, which I think has been there ever since. I think that's one of the big reasons why I would choose him. Maybe the other reason I would choose him is that he's one of the first to blend Japan's own style of pictorial art, which goes back centuries, with a modern style from Europe and particularly from America. Disney was a really big influence of his. So he brings those together, I think, quite successfully. And he manages very quickly to start exporting that.
也能去理解它，而不在成年生活中被其吸引或愚弄。所以他赋予了日本漫画和动画这种特质，我认为这种特质一直延续至今。我想这是我选择他的一个主要原因。也许我选择他的另一个原因，是他是最早将日本本土拥有几个世纪历史的绘画风格与来自欧洲、尤其是美国的现代风格相融合的人之一。迪士尼对他有非常大的影响。所以我觉得他相当成功地将这些结合在了一起。而且他设法非常迅速地开始将其出口。
So the great Atom Boy ends up on NBC in America. And it's a proud moment in Japan. This is the first time after the war that Japan has, as it were, spoken back to the West. And so I think it's a really important moment. And his influence is running all the way down to the present day in Japan. I found that element fascinating because he was in, I mean, he, you know, obviously he was a young man, wasn't he? A student during the war in Osaka. So he was, he was, he, you know, obviously he was a young man, wasn't he? A student. Yes, a medical student. In Osaka. So he knew the experience of bombing.
因此，伟大的《铁臂阿童木》最终登上了美国的NBC电视台。这是日本历史上的一个自豪时刻，这是战后日本第一次向西方“回话”。所以我觉得这是一个非常重要的时刻。他的影响一直延续到今天的日本。我发现这个元素非常迷人，因为他曾身处其中——我的意思是，他显然是一个年轻人，对吧？战争期间在大阪的一个学生。所以他曾是，他曾是，他显然是一个年轻人，对吧？一个学生。是的，是一个医学生。在大阪。所以他了解被轰炸的经历。
Yes. He wasn't hurt himself, but he knew what Japan had suffered at the hands of the Americans and the Allies, as the Japanese would undoubtedly have perceived it. And yet, Walt Disney is his great hero, and he learns from disney and he basically wants you know he has this dream of being the japanese walt disney and i suppose what i mean that the the great thing about focusing on these individuals is it allows us to sort of to see patterns and themes and actually that relationship between japan and america is a fascinating one because you would think there would be more bad blood, more resentment, you know, sort of festering rage, especially after the atomic bombings and the firebombing of Tokyo.
他自己没有受伤，但他了解日本在美国和盟军手下所遭受的痛苦，日本人无疑是这么认为的。然而，华特·迪士尼是他的大英雄，他向迪士尼学习，他基本上想要——你知道，他有成为“日本华特·迪士尼”的梦想。我想我的意思是，聚焦于这些个人的伟大之处在于，它允许我们去观察模式和主题，实际上，日本和美国之间的这种关系是一个迷人的关系，因为你本以为会有更多的恶感、更多的怨恨、你知道的，那种 festering rage（心头暗恨），特别是经历了原子弹轰炸和东京大轰炸之后。
So why doesn't he, I mean, why, why doesn't he just think Walt Disney, you know, the representative of this culture that, you know, was our great antagonist and we, we haven't forgiven them and all this stuff. Why does he throw himself so wholeheartedly into this sort of Disney adoration? I think you could probably place someone like Tezuka alongside some of Japan's great scientists and writers from this era, which is they want to create a new order
所以他为什么不——我的意思是，他为什么不直接认为华特·迪士尼，你知道的，代表了这种文化的化身，而这种文化曾经是我们的大对头，我们还没有原谅他们，等等这一切？为什么他要如此全心全意地投入到这种对迪士尼的崇拜中呢？我想你可以把像手冢治虫这样的人与这一时期日本的一些伟大科学家和作家放在一起，他们想要建立一个新秩序，
which is really international and which forges links between different countries to make sure that what they've just been through is completely impossible in the future. So for someone like Tezuka, that's the kind of world that he aspires to. And he sees what he does, his art, as having that sort of universal appeal. So I think that's probably one part of it. I think the other part of it is for a lot of Japanese people, by 1945, it had been obvious for a couple of years already that they'd been sold a lie in terms of the prospectus for war which their government had offered them they'd
这个秩序真正具有国际性，并且在不同国家之间建立联系，以确保他们刚刚经历过的那一切在未来绝对不可能再次发生。所以对于手冢治虫这样的人来说，这就是他所向往的世界。他认为他所做的事情、他的艺术，具有那种普世的吸引力。所以我想这可能是其中的一部分。我想另一部分原因是，对于许多日本人在1945年来说，几年之前就已经显而易见的是，他们的政府提供给他们的战争前景是一个谎言，他们
been through rationing they'd seen their children taken away and sacrificed on the battlefields and then they'd suffered this cataclysm of the firebombing and the atomic bombs and for a lot of people they just wanted to have the summer of 1945 as a year zero, as start again, pick up after this, you know, what some people call the dark valley. So I think that there's both. There's that sense of Tezuka
经历了配给制，他们看到自己的孩子被带走并在战场上牺牲，然后他们又遭受了火攻和原子弹的大灾难，对于许多人来说，他们只是想把1945年的夏天当作零年（Year Zero），当作一切的重新开始，在这之后重新振作，你知道的，有些人称之为“黑暗山谷”。所以我觉得两者兼而有之。既有手冢治虫想要通过艺术超越自我并真正走向国际化的那层意思，
wanting to transcend with his art and be truly international. And the other, which is just most Japanese wanted to start again. The flip side of that, of course, has been that from some people's point of view, the Japanese haven't really reflected on that wartime period in the way that, for example, Germany did. That's probably another debate.
另一方面，也就是大多数日本人都想重新开始。当然，硬币的另一面是，从某些人的观点来看，日本人并没有真正反思那个战期，就像德国人所做的那样。这大概是另一个争论。
But I think that moment of 1945 as being a switch was very powerful in Japan. But that parallel with Germany, just to say, actually, there are an awful lot of Germans going into the 1950s and beyond who, when interviewed by social scientists, would say, Hitler had the right ideas, he just went too far. I was a year zero in a blank slate and suddenly they were all cuddly social democrats is a myth is that true of Japan or is it did people just want to to not talk about it at all or were people genuine and repentant or what was the the mood more broadly would you say I think for the war itself there was a genuine sense of not wanting to speak about it. And it remains an enormous issue in Japanese politics and its relationships, you know, with countries like South Korea now. But I think on the other hand, there's something there that does parallel Germany, which is that although Japan, first country in the world, have a constitution authored by another power, you know, authored by
但我想1945年作为一个转折点的时刻在日本是非常强大的。但与德国的平行对比，只是想说，实际上，有相当多的德国人在进入20世纪50年代及以后时，当被社会科学家采访时，会说希特勒的想法是正确的，他只是做得太过分了。战后成为“零年”和一张白纸，然后突然他们都成了温和的社会民主党人，这是一个神话。这适用于日本吗？还是说人们只是不想谈论它？或者人们是真诚的忏悔？你认为更广泛的氛围是什么？我认为对于战争本身，有一种不愿谈论它的真诚心态。而且它仍然是日本政治及其与韩国等国家关系中的一个巨大问题。但我想另一方面，那里确实有一些与德国相似的东西，那就是尽管日本成为世界上第一个拥有由另一个国家（即由
the Americans, the 1946 constitution, there was an attempt in japanese culture i think you could say after the war across decades to slowly push back against some of the liberal reforms that the americans tried to make as being basically un-japanese one classic example would be don't fool around with the japanese family there's a role for the father there's a role for the mother and the role for the mother doesn't include being out there having a full-time job, neglecting the upbringing of the children, etc, etc. There's a sense that that is a uniquely Japanese institution, however familiar the basics I've just given might sound from elsewhere, and that the Americans should never have fooled around with it. And so there's a big cultural pushback, I think, in Japan against that.
美国人）起草的宪法的国家——1946年宪法，但在日本文化中，我想你可以说在战后几十年里，有一种缓慢的努力，去反击美国人试图做出的一些自由主义改革，认为这些改革基本上是不符合日本国情的。一个经典的例子就是：不要胡乱干涉日本的家庭，父亲有父亲的角色，母亲有母亲的角色，而母亲的角色不包括外出找一份全职工作、忽视对孩子的抚育，等等，等等。人们认为这是一个独特的日本制度，尽管我刚举的这些基础知识在其他地方可能听起来很熟悉，而美国人本不该干涉它。所以我想日本对此有一股强大的文化反弹。
Right, because one of the things about Tezuka that is really striking is that even as you're talking about Japan wanting this year zero, that actually manga, which seems the embodiment of everything that's most cutting edge and futuristic about Japan for foreigners, is absolutely drawing on these very ancient traditions. So the originating traditions of manga I learned from you go right the way back to the time of Murasaki, back to the 11th century. And these picture scrolls that are showing people drinking, what is it, rotten potatoes so that they can have fart battles. Yeah, the fart battles, absolutely. I mean, that's a great detail. You don't get that in Murasaki, do you? It's wonderful.
没错，因为关于手冢治虫有一点非常引人注目，那就是尽管你在谈论日本想要这个零年，但实际上漫画（在外国人看来似乎是日本最具前卫和未来感的一切的化身）绝对是在汲取这些非常古老的传统的营养。所以我从你那里了解到，漫画的起源传统一直可以追溯到紫式部时期，追溯到11世纪。这些画卷展示了人们喝着什么来着——烂土豆，以便进行放屁比赛。是的，放屁比赛，绝对是的。我的意思是，这是一个极好的细节。你在紫式部的作品里看不到这个，对吧？这太棒了。
And you've got the satire of having Buddhist priests or Buddhist robes on the bodies of monkeys and frogs, etc. Yeah, there's a wonderful humorous tradition in Japan, which we maybe don't always associate the Japanese with. So nice to have that in there. And also we talked about the onigata in Kabuki, the men who play women. Yes.
而且你还有那种讽刺，比如让佛教僧侣或穿着袈裟的身体变成猴子和青蛙等等。是的，日本有一种奇妙的幽默传统，我们可能并不总是把这种传统与日本人联系在一起。所以能在其中看到这一点真好。而且我们还谈到了歌舞伎中的“女形”，也就是扮演女性的男性。是的。
And again, this is this theme of the male and the female being in the same body, the kind of slippage between the sexes, is also there in Tezuka's manga, isn't it? Because he has a princess who is brought up as a boy, but has a man's soul. And that sense of kind of androgyny which is another theme running back through japanese history is there in his his his manga yeah absolutely i think you can as you say you can trace that back at least as far as kabuki via this lovely um takarazuka review um troop in osaka you know which tezuka's mother takes him to regularly um all women and they've got these amazing scenes
再次强调，这种男性和女性存在于同一个身体中的主题，也就是两性之间的模糊界限，也存在于手冢治虫的漫画中，不是吗？因为他有一个被当作男孩养大、却有着男人灵魂的公主。那种双性同体的感觉——这也是贯穿日本历史的另一个主题——就存在于他的漫画中。是的，绝对是的。我想正如你所说，通过大阪这个可爱的“宝冢歌舞剧团”（手冢的母亲经常带他去那里）——全都是女性，而且她们有这些惊人的场景——你至少可以把这一点一直追溯到歌舞伎。
from everywhere from ancient China to Egypt to medieval Europe. So there's a mixture of the androgyny and the fantasy that I think goes into his work. I mean, I wonder whether part of the robustness of that tradition in Japan's manga and anime is that it is, to use an awful phrase, a kind of cultural safe space in Japan where things that are going on out there in the country, whether it's conservative values, women struggling in the workplace, etc.
从古代中国、埃及到中世纪欧洲，无所不包。因此我认为他的作品中融合了两性同体和奇幻色彩。我的意思是，我很好奇这种传统在日本漫画和动画中之所以如此生命力顽强，是不是因为——用一个不太恰当的词来说——它在日本算是一种文化上的“安全区”，在这里你可以探讨现实社会中正在发生的事情，比如保守的价值观、女性在职场中的挣扎等等。
And the difficulty of discussing some things in public in out-and-out political terms, you can process them in this world of fantasy instead, which I think Japan has become very, very good at doing in that Tezuka tradition. And it has an incredible international appeal. Yeah. So it may be very, very Japanese, but it also has this incredible resonance. Absolutely. Although the interesting thing about that,
以及在公开场合用直白的政治语言讨论某些事情的难度，取而代之的是，你可以在这个奇幻的世界里去处理这些问题，我认为日本在手冢治虫的这种传统下，已经把这一点做得非常非常出色。而且它具有极强的国际吸引力。是的。所以它可能非常非常日本化，但它同时也具有这种惊人的共鸣。完全同意。不过有趣的是，
I often ask my students from places like China and South Korea, and they come in and they love Studio Ghibli, you know, Miyazaki Hayao. I said, well, how does that make you feel about, you know, the 1940s? They said it absolutely doesn't change our minds at all. What we hear from our grandmothers, our great grandmothers, etc., that remains for us central in our image of Japan. And yet at the same time, whether it's cognitive dissonance or not, I don't know, we can perfectly well enjoy a lovely Miyazaki film
我经常问来自中国和韩国等地的学生，他们来了之后都很喜欢吉卜力工作室，也就是宫崎骏的作品。我问，那这会让你对20世纪40年代有什么感觉吗？他们说这完全不会改变我们的想法。我们从祖母、曾祖母那里听到的事情，对我们来说依然是我们对日本印象的核心。但与此同时，不管这算不算认知失调，我不知道，我们完全可以尽情欣赏一部精彩的宫崎骏电影，
and really get into the whole world of feeling and aesthetics that it offers. So, Japan, a land of contrast. Unbelievable. That was brilliant, Chris. And the great thing about that is not only does it make me want to go and watch loads of Japanese films immediately, but it opens up so many avenues for us to pursue in the rest of history. Yeah, it does.
并真正融入它所呈现的情感和美学世界中。所以，日本真是一个充满对比的国度。难以置信。克里斯，太精彩了。最棒的是，这不仅让我立刻想去看大量的日本电影，而且为我们在接下来的历史探讨中开拓了如此多的途径。是的，确实如此。
Don't you think? It really does. So many interesting things from samurai to manga. And it's a brilliant book the japanese a history in 20 lives uh it was one of my regular listeners will know that i like to make book recommendations based on my sunday times reviews don't i tom yes and it was one of my books of the year a couple of years ago tom is there is there a finer honor in the literary world skilled ambitious a marvelous study, a marvellous study of edition, I think you said. And it's emblazoned on the front of the paperback copy that I've got here. So highly, highly recommended.
你不觉得吗？真的很有趣。从武士到漫画，有那么多有趣的东西。《日本人：20个生命中的历史》这本书真是太棒了，正如我的老听众们所知道的那样，我喜欢根据我在《星期日泰晤士报》上的书评来推荐书，对吧，汤姆？是的，几年前它曾被评为我的年度好书之一。汤姆，文学界还有比这更高的荣誉吗？“技艺精湛、雄心勃勃的精彩研究，一部极好的版本研究”，我想你是这么说的。我手里这本平装书的封面上就印着这句话。所以强烈、强烈推荐。
Chris, thanks so much. Thank you for having me. But the great thing about Chris and this episode, Tom, was his lovely endorsement of my Japanese at the beginning. And I think that's what a lot of listeners will take from today. I think that's the one blot on the copybook. Otherwise, an exemplary exemplary performance so chris thanks so much and thank you everyone for listening
克里斯，非常感谢。谢谢你邀请我。但克里斯和这一集最棒的地方，汤姆，在于他一开始对我的日语水平的美妙夸奖。我想这也是很多听众会从今天的节目中记住的内容。我认为那是这页纸上唯一的污点。除此之外，这是一场无可挑剔的模范表现。所以克里斯，非常感谢你，也谢谢大家的收听。
and we will be back again tomorrow bye-bye sayonara thanks for listening to the rest is history episodes, early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip.
我们明天再见，拜拜，再见。感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。想要获取往期节目、抢先收听、无广告体验以及进入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦八卦。
And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家播客以及抢先购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。